this is CBS news color coverage of man
on the moon rockets tranquility we can't
be on the ground you got a bunch of guys
about to turn blue so the great Walter
Cronkite was clearly a little bit
overwhelmed in that moment and many
Americans were as well and people all
around the world but the idea that the
Apollo missions were super popular in
the 1960s it's just not true I think it
was a terrific feat but it makes you
wonder whether or not to get our
priorities and order actually they don't
mean anything to me because I can't I
don't know the meaning what they want to
go that's what well I feel to waste the
money another thing about the space
program like everybody's paying taxes
they don't have any Puerto Ricans Negro
or Cuban space people going up why not
what about the 24 billion that were
spent to get a man to the moon and it's
not worth it
no way in the world so that was how
people thought about the Apollo mission
50 years ago we were curious has
anyone's thinking changed on the subject
and also NASA wants to go back to the
moon and spend 20 to 30 billion dollars
to do so how do people feel about that
we're here in Central Park
you might say on a mission let's see
what we can find there's nobody we got
nobody what do you say to NASA's new
mission
I think NASA needs a new administrator
it's not to go back to the moment that's
a waste of money go back to the moon
we've been there go to Mars no why I've
been there Mars
if we can get there yes how do you feel
about Apollo fifty years later I don't
really care it cost about a hundred and
seventy billion dollars in today's money
is that worth it
probably not I think there's bigger
issues in the world the fact that like
okay we're having to explore Mars
because they think we're gonna have to
like get sent there in a few years
because our Earth's gonna be like gone
so why don't we spend that money
actually doing something so we can stay
here then figure that out later all
right come on we're gonna check on these
people on the bench excuse me everyone
sorry to interrupt you I know you're
enjoying a nice sunny day and oh you're
getting out of here okay quick question
for you fiftieth anniversary of Apollo
is coming up on Tuesday we got people
running for it what's it worth it the
moon mission yes why I think it's a
pretty awesome thing I think it was
worth it I think space exploration is
good yeah probably should do more of it
how do you feel about NASA's plan to go
back to the moon I think it should be
done
I'd like my kids to be able to see
something like that happen in their
lifetime worth can mean more than just
money I mean I think wandering curiosity
it's all tied up in worth also so I you
know I do from that perspective I think
absolutely it's worth it worth it can
mean more than just money I like that